[Música]
[Aplausos]
mi primera experiencia consciente con un
super humano fue en enero del 2020
estaba a punto de morir con una
hemorragia cerebral y en mi hermana
melissa se despertaron poderes más allá
del mundo visible sobre su fragilidad
cargo
financiamientos decisiones médicas
cirugías viajes y pudo
pudo conmigo con ella pudo con todo y lo
hizo por amor
luego sentí ese mismo fenómeno en mi
interior cuando estaba más vulnerable mi
mente mi cuerpo y mi espíritu se
elevaron en un potencial que no creía
posible
al inicio sufrir de amnesia y de
delirios por la hidrocefalia
yo siento que mi cuerpo evito que mi
mente perdón evito que mi cuerpo se
dejara morir creando un mundo fantástico
que me mantenía protegida y resguardada
un mundo casi quijotesco donde me
refugiaba
las personas entraban a verme terapia
intensiva llorando y salían riendo con
las historias locas que les contaba no
solo para mantenerme viva sino revestida
de ánimo y de alegría
un día inventaba que era manager de
artistas famosos otro día inventaba que
mis perros venían a visitarme y que
conversábamos fluidamente tengo ocho
perros otro día me inventé que mi gato
me arranco la vía del suero y en
realidad yo me la había arrancado para
pararme a bailar en la camilla porque
quería bailar otro día empecé a escribir
mi primera novela desde terapia
intensiva escribía canciones entré a mi
primera cirugía cantando bonnie y
bailando con las enfermeras por favor no
me juzguen no estaba en mis cabales
[Aplausos]
[Música]
fueron días blindadas en un dulce
delirio
en el que conectada a tantas máquinas
pero desconectada del mundo empezaba a
crecer en mi interior una fuerza
interior indestructible en un par de
meses pasé por dos cirugías de cerebro
la primera en la que me colocaron un
catéter en la cabeza que termina en el
estómago y que sigo teniendo
para recordarme siempre que nunca más
será la misma que hubo un momento en el
que evolucione a una mejor versión como
mujer un poco mutante sí pero mejor y
una segunda cirugía en la que heroicos
médicos se previeron a surcar la zona
más inaccesible de mi cerebro la más
delicada que es la región pineal para
extraer finalmente el tumor que había
desencadenado todo
han sido tiempos en los que muchos lo
hemos perdido todo
pero que en esa pérdida hemos podido
resguardarnos resguardarnos en el
estoicismo para abrazar la vida con
mucha más fuerza que antes porque eso es
lo que producen las cicatrices que
fortalecen
mientras las probabilidades de muertes y
de daños colaterales eran altísimas
fueron cubriendo me a mi alrededor
tantos pero tantos
familiares amigos
clientes
desconocidos incluso personas desde otro
continente
superhumanos sensibilizados por mi causa
armados de una solidaridad
extraordinaria que nunca había visto
ellos me inundaron de un manantial de
amor me sentía totalmente resguardada se
levantó un ejército a mi alrededor yo no
estaba sola todos estaban luchando
conmigo desde diferentes dimensiones
y eso fue lo que ayudó que yo pueda
recuperarme que puede sanando que pueda
ver la vida nuevamente
con optimismo
que puede alimentar mis ganas de
continuar viviendo y de siendo y de ser
mucho mejor que lo que era antes
aquí hay algunos de los mensajes
preciosos que voy a guardar por siempre
y que voy a convertir en un mural en mí
en mi estudio
hoy parada en este escenario soy la
prueba de que el amor es la fuerza para
sanar el mundo
pero aquí no termina la historia
jamás imaginé que este era sólo el
tráiler de un año casi de ciencia
ficción el
la realidad que todos conocíamos se
fracturó como en un videojuego y todos
saltamos de golpe como si nos hubieran
dado una patada a una nueva realidad con
distintas fases de prueba
fue en ese momento que empecé a verlos
por todos lados
alimentando sus sueños desde el anémico
confinamiento que todos vivimos
salvando vidas desde los pasillos y las
terapias intensivas y abarrotadas de
enfermos
inspirados en tomar acciones positivas
para mejorar sus vidas
rediseñando se para adaptarse a los
nuevos modelos del mercado
huyéndole a 0 normales porque el mundo
ya no es normal y nunca lo será
comprometidos a actuar por cuenta propia
por el medio ambiente y el futuro del
planeta sin esperar la intervención de
los gobiernos o las instituciones
activistas de la igualdad que luchan
para que existan las mismas
oportunidades en cuanto a raza género y
poder adquisitivo
comunidad de preverse personas que
buscan estar totalmente
preparadas para situaciones extremas ya
sea políticas climáticas
sanitarias
planificadoras ahorradoras mucho más
cautas
consumidores que ahora prefieren
comprarle a los pequeños negocios
locales
que se las han visto tan amargo en todo
este tiempo
mutantes mutables con una increíble
capacidad de adaptación que ahora se
pueden pueden convivir mucho más
fácilmente entre el mundo físico y el
mundo digital que saben que pueden
trabajar casi desde cualquier lugar
nómadas digitales
ciudadanos que hacen de doctores de su
propia salud que por el impacto que tuvo
la pandemia y el confinamiento en la
salud mental ahora pueden hablar con
mucha más apertura sobre las
enfermedades mentales sin sentirse
avergonzados que han creado escenarios
propicios para hablar de la depresión de
la ansiedad de los desórdenes del sueño
que reinventan sus rutinas para escapar
de todo aquello que significa alto
voltaje sin ambiciones de lo externo de
lo superficial que han logrado
rediseñar las prioridades en su vida que
realmente han entendido
cuál es el verdadero éxito en la vida
que comen con mayor conciencia
para estar más fuertes para elevar su
sistema inmune
picto kers creadores digitales que usan
su creatividad como armas de
supervivencia en fin
humanos que han tenido que aprender a
reiniciarse
a conquistar su relación con el peligro
y con la incertidumbre
para poder vivir en un mundo cada vez
menos predecible
nació lo que yo le llamo un nuevo meta
verso de superhumanos
y ahora mientras vamos superando la
pandemia
estamos practicando estilos de vida cada
vez más compatibles con un futuro
sostenible y nos preguntamos ahora y qué
hay de las marcas
es ahora que las marcas necesitan ser
más humanas que nunca el mundo ya no
necesita más marcas exitosas el mundo el
mundo necesita marcas más humanas marcas
relevantes marcas con propósito como
dice el gran juan y sasha marcas que
siembren esperanza que den ánimo que
ayuden a que la gente continúe soñando
alimentando sus motivaciones marcas que
tomen postura ante los diferentes
problemas sociales
marcas comprometidas con que las
personas puedan vivir mejor
esto es lo que la gente espera que sus
marcas que sus marcas tomen acciones
concretas
que ya no invitan a la gente a comprar
de manera caprichosa que tomen en cuenta
el estado anímico de sus sociedades
marcas que todas independientes del
rubro en el que se encuentre estén con
un pie dentro de la industria de la
salud marcas que abran un espacio a la
expresión y a la creatividad humanas
marca que no se tomen tan en serio que
sean más personas y menos corporaciones
las marcas ya no pueden seguir siendo
entes que fabrican productos y servicios
las marcas están llamadas a fabricar
contenido y experiencias relevantes para
el mundo emocional de los consumidores
marcas que en este nuevo juego de roles
interactúen y adopten avatares que le
den pelea a los males del mundo que nos
ayuden a todos en este proceso de
transformación que adopten avatares de
los sueños de bienestar adaptar es
ecológico avatares ecológicos avatares
de equidad avatares de seguridad que es
lo que todos necesitamos volver a sentir
avatares de educación porque las
personas necesitamos conocer recursos
para poder adaptarnos a este mundo tan
cambiante
marcas super humanas y muchas marcas en
todo el mundo han dado ese upgrade a un
segundo nivel y están adaptándose a esta
nueva realidad basta ver lo que está
sucediendo
mcdonald's que celebra que los amigos
nos vuelvan a robar las papas fritas y
algo queda totalmente molesto antes
ahora los celebramos porque extrañábamos
el contacto y mcdonald lo sabe y estar
usando ese insight humano para poder
generar la conexión marcas de té que
quieren luchar contra el suicidio y
juvenil y que lo hacen invitando a
muchos jóvenes a contar sus historias a
través de ilustraciones en sus packaging
y que ya están hablando de esto sin
vergüenza y de una forma mucho más
abierta volver kings que compartió su
receta con todos para que puedan cocinar
las hamburguesas durante la cuarentena
en un acto total
desprendimiento de empatía de entrega
chubut to go que lanzó una colección de
pósters contra el desperdicio de comida
pensando ya en la sostenibilidad del
planeta
pepsi que fantasea con la nueva
normalidad recordando los momentos
desastrosos que vivíamos antes de la
pandemia que nos hace reírnos de
nosotros mismos y valorar los pequeños
detalles que perdimos y que no estamos
seguros en qué momento vuelvan y en fin
marcas de cerveza que han montado una
oficina en medio de la montaña para
llevar el teletrabajo que es una
tendencia a otro nivel
lanzaron una marca totalmente
transgresora y valiente porque cambió su
logo por el de sus competidores
imagínense para hablar sobre el
reciclaje de las botellas hablando
nuevamente del futuro del planeta y del
cuidado de nuestro medio ambiente esta
acción de street marketing que surgió en
parís fascinante ya que los cines no
funcionaron donde muchísimo durante
muchísimo tiempo pusieron a disposición
fachadas y sus carteleras para que los
suns los pequeños negocios locales
puedan promocionarse es justamente lo
que les hablaba hace un momento
estoy a punto de cumplir 20 años de
carrera publicitaria sé que no se me
nota
pero
en este camino he transitado
desde
la cultura urbana en mis inicios he
pasado por el la tele y con la fundación
de mis empresas win y molotov me
especializado en la creación de
experiencias de marca y de branded
content buscando siempre conectar de una
manera más humana y emocionante a las
marcas con sus públicos
hoy estoy segura que este camino
alternativo que seguir dentro de la
publicidad dentro de la publicidad no
tradicional no fue casualidad
así como tampoco es casualidad que hoy
me siga bombeando el corazón después de
este proceso de reset personal y del
mundo tengo un propósito mayor el de
contar historias para ayudar a las
personas y a las marcas a adaptarse a
esta nueva realidad en un nivel superior
de conciencia y de amor tengo el
propósito de que seamos mejor que todo
lo que conocíamos antes
super humanos
todos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
tú
[Música]
i
que no puedan los sueños que no se
apaguen
[Música]
es que la esperanza que no sé para qué
i
vamos caminando
dejando huellas
compartiendo miradas
a mí me enciendo
[Música]
caminando
[Risas]
por la vida juntos
gracias gracias
[Aplausos]